hey this is presh to Walker Ann is late
to a meeting already in progress and a
few people give her the evil eye
after she joins the room the average age
of all people in the room increases by
exactly four years a few minutes later
her twin sister Beth joins the meeting
and the average age of all people in the
room increases Again by exactly three
years how many people were in the room
before Anne entered
I think Dieter from Germany for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
let's set up some variables let N be the
number of people in the room before Anne
joined let M be their average age and
let a be equal to Anne's age be equal to
BET's age
let's keep track of the number of people
in the room and their average age
so at the start before Anne joined there
are n people and their average age is m
after Anne joins the number of people
increases by one so that'll be n plus
one
then the average age will be M plus 4.
after Beth joins the number of people
increases Again by one so this will be n
plus two and the average again increases
This Time by three years so we have M
plus four plus three
let's now take a look at the sum of the
ages of all the people in the room
this will be the number of people
multiplied by the average age
so at the start it'll be n times M then
after and joins it'll be n plus 1
multiplied by M plus four
but we also know that it increases by
the age of n so we can take the sum of
the ages before Anne was there which is
NM and then we add Anne's age of a so
it'll also be equal to NM plus a
after Beth joins the sum of all the ages
will be n plus 2 multiplied by M plus
seven but we could also take the
previous sum and then add Beth's age
so we take NM plus a and then we add a
again because Beth and N are the same
age so this will be NM plus 2A
let's now take a look at the sum of the
ages in these two cases
so we have two equivalent ways to
express the sum of the ages so they will
be equal to each other so we have one
equation
then we will have another equation
so now let's simplify these equations
we will expand the first binomial
then the NM terms on both sides cancel
out
so we have 4N plus M plus four is equal
to a
in the second equation we expand the
binomial the NM terms cancel out so then
we have 7n plus two M plus 14 is equal
to 2A
we're now getting pretty close
we now just need to eliminate the a
variable and the M variable to solve for
the N variable so we will multiply the
first equation by 2 to get eight n plus
two M plus eight is equal to 2A we then
subtract the second equation from this
so we get n minus 6 is equal to 0 which
means n is equal to six and that's the
answer there were six people in the room
before and joined
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign